by the end of six and the grounds almost
all of the characters have gone through
complete ups the themes have been
clearly stated and explored and the pipe
has been laid the inevitable sequel you
were probably just too busy watching
things blow up to notice six underground
foreshadows ending to its main plot
fairly early about half an hour into the
movie we see a flashback in which one is
in Paris where he meets a dictator of
Turkistan robach at a performance of
Shakespeare's Richard the third it's an
important meeting
Roback smug attitude convinces one to
found his own power military
organization once it's up and running
Roback is its first target the play
offers one AMRO fact the opportunity to
trade barbs about all tyrants always get
their comeuppance
but the parallels between Rove acts
downfall and Richard the third run
deeper than that in the play Richard
keeps his brother Clarence locked away
in a tower where he can't interfere with
Richards plans Roebuck does the same
thing to his brother just swap the Tower
of London for a Hong Kong skyscraper in
addition before Richards downfall he's
visited by an army of ghosts who predict
us demise
naturally it's ones group of ghosts who
invade Turkestan turn the citizens
against robic and break into the
dictators yachts
leading to robux death ultimately it's
not a bad thing
the closer the ghost gets the better
they work together the more successful
they become and the happier they are by
the end of the movie there are family
that is functional one sure but a family
just the same despite what one says he
desperately wants a family you get a
hint of that early on when you see that
the plane he crashes to faked his death
is full of pictures of his girlfriend
even once turned towards vigilantism is
sparked by family he's inspired to found
the ghost when delivering medical
supplies to Turkestan a stopped us more
about photo ops and really helping
people and sees firsthand what happens
when Rho vac uses chemical weapons on
his own people as one passes out gas
masks it's not the mass suffering that
makes one we consider his life choices
it's the plight of a few children
separated from their families ultimately
one accepts up personal connections make
you stronger not weaker after stopping
ro VAX reign of terror one returns to
New York he clandestinely follows his ex
and realizes that she has a
four-year-old blond-haired child we
don't know for sure that the kid is once
but it seems pretty likely before one
thought yet to give up his life to
above us now he has something to live
for and he's even more willing to fight
for it almost every ghost goes through a
very similar journey when she was with
the CIA
- ignored her emotions and followed
orders she knew were wrong three was
disowned by his elderly mother for his
violent job which ended up opening a
young girl four was abandoned by his
friends after a heist went sour
all of them decide to give up their
normal lives to join one hoping to find
Redemption along the way every one of
these characters find salvation in their
family after two and three hookup in Las
Vegas through let's down her emotional
barriers and pursues a real relationship
three introduces to to his mom and the
son of mother reconcile after the ghost
rescue for from danger not once but
twice
the reformed thief realises he finally
has friends he can trust six and the
ground begins with a lot of talk about
the freedom death provides but ends with
a monologue detailing how life gives us
purpose that's not an accident
sevim played by Corey Hawkins has a
slightly different tack 7 already has
people who loved him he didn't join the
team until after six ties throwing the
ghosts first mission leaving an opening
in the squad before joining the ghosts 7
or plane was an Army sniper stationed in
Afghanistan one day while surveilling a
meeting he spots a terrorist
masquerading as a UN representative
Blaine asked his superiors for
permission to shoot the man but they
decline a bomb explodes killing many of
plane's fellow soldiers traumatized to
blame returns home to find one waiting
for him with an offer what if he could
take down bad guys just like the ones
that killed his fellow soldiers and I
will never tell you to not pull that
trigger what would you say to that
that's all that Blaine needs to sign up
except it's not exactly true the rest of
the ghosts don't trust seven and one
constantly subs Blaine from following
his instincts when one tells seven to
abandon four who's being chased by the
bad guys the former soldier of a belt
after Afghanistan he won't lose another
comrade he pulls a gun on three who's
driving and forces everyone to wait
until four later seven is the one who
encourages everyone to share their real
names join the film's climax when one
goes back to save four from certain
death we see how much force rubbed off
on him ultimately seven is the one who
brings a team together
he might have joined the ghost for
different reasons than everyone else but
they wouldn't have become a family
without him
by the end of six on the ground the
ghosts have created a queue in tyrgyztan
wrote back his dead and his
pro-democracy brother as in control the
civilians have been saved from another
round of chemical weapon attacks the
squad is happy the mission is done but
it's just the first mission as one
explains earlier in the movie Rho vac
was just a first name on the ghosts hit
list there are eight more despite all of
the setbacks the ghost made the world a
slightly better place but their work
isn't done there are still bad people
out there and the ghosts are going to
take a mouse in other words if six
underground is a hits Michael Bay and
writers Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick
have already planted the seeds for up to
eight sequels hope you like six
Underground's unique concoction of
mayhem you might be watching these
movies forever
hope so check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]